jamaika ist gescheitert jetzt liegt alle
hoffnung auf der spd gerade uns gott auf
dieser regionalkonferenz soll die basis
neue vorschläge einbringen aber ist die
basis auch seriös genug
ich bin für eine programmatische
veränderung nehmen spd muss richtig
elegante gehen ja weil wir müssen wieder
der 17 jahre zurück ist es dann wichtig
jetzt auch ein bisschen jugendlicher
rüberzukommen ich sehe sie als sind ja
entsprechend schon mal angezogen nicht
nur johanna mit intelligenz ein bisschen
intelligenter rüberzukommen der darum
die verkleidung auch verkleidung ich bin
ich war das übrigens ein stuhl von
schaaf von der frauen bundesliga sg
essen und sie sind wirklich richtig
motiviert ist nicht richtig fahrt auf
absolut motiviert ich bin immer
motiviert es wirklich wir wollen jetzt
sehe ich jetzt nicht den kanzler als es
jetzt ist er wieder weg
nein aber wird es nicht das ist ja
wieder da absolut es ist aber doch ganz
wichtig dass wir jetzt wirklich
gemeinsam anfang zu kämpfen
absolut
geht man es ja so ist das noch nicht
ausreichend seien
als wäre spd wäre das wort gewesen
genial dass mit der kappe haben sich von
trump abgeguckt oder nicht die habe ich
schon vortrag war zwar schon wo ich
wobei ich bemerken musste er sich herrn
trump kenne sie kennen hand ram ja den
habe ich mal in new york getroffen und
da hat er den befehl gegeben mich zu
erschießen mich zu erschießen
chili hat er gesagt zu seinen
leibwächtern und quatchi geschichte
jetzt ist einfach unsinn
er wollte mich von sich entfernt haben
der mit der roten karte hat behauptet
trump wollte ihn erschießen auf der
fifth avenue
man muss natürlich auch die größte frage
der hitze nur streit geraten lassen sie
ihren frust raus schreien sie einfluss
jetzt schreien sie in wustrau scheiße
ich weiß was die spd retten kann
eine bürgersprechstunde in der
bimmelbahn wie finden sie das
hervorragend ganz großartig frage ich
mir gedacht da gehe ich jetzt nicht hier
hin
ja das war nämlich gar kein witz von mir
die bürgersprechstunde gibt es wirklich
und rätselhafte weise findet sie in der
bimmelbahn statt wasser 74 ein
gemeindepfarrer volksabstimmung
herr schäfer ist das jetzt hier der
schulz zug von dem man schon so viel
gehört hat
nein das ist eine historische
straßenbahn wo interessierte bürgerinnen
und bürger dass bochum fahren also nicht
der schulz zu gut für schulz ist es hier
auch viel zu schnell und hitze modernen
muss man sagen aber das stimmt nicht
also das ist eine eine historische
straßenbahn
die ist zwar modernisiert worden aber
martin schulz ich schon moderne als
diese bahn steht auf wenn ihr genossen
seit steht auf denn irgendwo bereitsteht
der erste tag für die spd deshalb hab
ich mich kurzerhand ans steuer gesetzt
was die aber noch nicht wissen ich
mach's wie christian lindner und steigt
bei voller fahrt aus spd
[Applaus]